le couvre-feu à 18 heures est entre en
vigueur le 2 janvier dans 15
départements jusqu'à sa généralisation
de semaine plus tard les premiers
résultats positifs se font visiblement
attendre le couvre-feu à 18h à ce stade
en effet une efficacité relative qui est
réel mais qui n'est pas suffisante
à ce stade c'est donc en anticipation
avant de tirer les conclusions au bout
des deux semaines que nous envisageons
plusieurs scénarios les effets
définitive du couvre-feu seront mesurés
cette semaine sur le plan national la
situation épidémique témoigne d'une
circulation active du virus et de ses
nouveaux variants un plateau haut qui
augmente une incidence qui augmente une
pression sur l'hôpital qui augmente
une diffusion des variants qui est à
l'évidence importante et rapide et c'est
dans ces conditions que nous avions
appris en anticipation le couvre-feu
avancé à 18 heures évidemment les
spéculations vont bon train si gabriel
attal n'a pas manqué de souligner la
lassitude de beaucoup de français un
troisième confinement strict pourraient
être considérées alors à quel scénario
faut-il s'attendre ce sont plusieurs
scénarios qui vont d'un maintien du
cadre actuel avec le couvre-feu à 18h
jusqu'à un confinement très serré et que
dans le même temps des concertations
vont être menées par le premier ministre
à la demande du président de la
république avec le comité de liaison
parlementaires les groupes
parlementaires représentés au parlement
avec les partenaires sociaux et les
associations d'élus
ces concertations approfondies vont se
dérouler dans les tout prochains jours
une seule alternative a été
définitivement rejetée imposer un
confinement aux personnes âgées n'est
pas une option envisagée par emmanuel
macron